hello everyone please join me in
welcoming Mary Grace mesta who will be
talking about ml Ops deployment patterns
with Delta and ml flow thank you Mary
Grace
[Applause]
hey everybody
um I understand it's the end of the day
on Thursday so hopefully I can keep you
guys entertained and short and sweet
um and informative so as she said I'm
here to talk a little bit more about
deployment patterns and specifically how
Delta and ml flow to open source pieces
of Technology can be really helpful in
managing some of the pieces of
deployment
in terms of what we'll cover I'll just
do a brief introduction about myself uh
we'll kind of frame things a little bit
by talking about why you should care
about ml apps deployment and why it can
be really difficult and challenging
we'll do a quick primer on Delta and
mlflow just so everyone's kind of on the
same page in terms of understanding the
basics of the Technologies we'll then go
through kind of the deployment patterns
outline what those look like and then
really dive into talking about how Delta
and mlflow specifically can help with
the reproducibility pieces of the
deployment patterns and the audit pieces
and some additional deployment
optimizations and then at the very end
we'll kind of have a brief discussion on
cicd
um so uh like I said my name is Mary
Grace mesta um if you can't tell by my
slide I'm a Taylor Swift fan
um but I'm a senior data science
consultant from databricks I've been
there for about four over four years now
um where my time they're spent doing a
lot of all things data science and
recently it's been quite a bit of ml Ops
and ml engineering type work I'm based
in Detroit Michigan so the the Sun and
no snow here in Seattle has been a
really nice change of pace
all right so uh let's kind of dive into
it and talk about why ml deployment is
hard and start by talking about why you
should care now if you're in this room
my guess is you probably care about it a
little bit maybe not at all if not
hopefully after the slide you care
um but uh like I said I'm a practitioner
at heart so to me the fun parts of data
science are the exploratory work the
hyper parameters tuning the you know the
modeling trying out new algorithms is
like that's all the fun pieces but when
we kind of go back to like why we're
doing all this
it's really to deliver value to to
someone something or some entity right
and unfortunately the building of models
isn't always super valuable but the
delivering of those models is what's
really driving the value
um so you know delivering the models is
deployment so how we can bridge the gap
between the fun parts of data science
and the value is is deployment now when
we think about well-runner deployments
what does that mean a couple pieces here
of of like what I think of when I think
of a good well-rounded deployment the
first are the fact that the results are
really high quality so as you move up in
environments you know from Dev to
staging to prod so does the quality of
your artifacts across those environments
and the second piece and I'll kind of
reiterate this like several times
throughout the presentation but it's an
automation first mentality so automating
your processes through the deployment
process is kind of twofold first it
contributes to that high quality or High
Fidelity results in the sense of the
less manual processes you have the
smaller room for human error which again
kind of furthers that qual body in your
production environment
and the second piece is just saving
people time right like if you have these
really intense manually intense
deployment processes it's time you're
taking away from other projects from
other people so automating it kind of
again provides that quality piece and
also saves a whole bunch of time
uh the other thing is about deployments
and the development of new features into
your system so when you have a well
automated well-rounded deployment
solution doing things like adding a
different feature set changing your
hyper parameter tuning optimization
techniques right all of that becomes
much easier to implement and roll into
production faster if you can just you
know change your code and plug it into
the rest of the process and it deploys
smoothly without anyone having to touch
it without having to wait on anyone's
approval
so now hopefully everyone cares about ml
deployment let's talk about why again
it's not easy and this is kind of again
a summary of like what I've I've seen in
my my experience but the first piece is
there's always a learning curve
Associated
um and so deployment kind of comes in
two different ways we see sometimes data
science teams are responsible for
deploying ml systems and the learning
curve there is oftentimes the data
science Community isn't super familiar
with Automation and CI CD tools so
there's a huge learning curve of trying
to get up to speed and just trying to
you know wrap your head around what the
heck is Jenkins how do I use it and how
can it be helpful to me as a data
scientist
on the other hand when we had these like
devops or deployment teams responsible
for developing the models
um they're sometimes not super well
versed in data science so like the
nuances of deploying a data science
system has to be learned as well so
there's like the data science piece of
that learning curve when we see the
deployment Happening by a deployment or
like a CI CD team so that kind of again
makes things a little bit more
challenging because there's always
something new that someone has to learn
to be able to do this
um the other piece I think one of the
larger ones is again with any ml
experiment there's so much to keep track
of right you have the model you have the
data you have the environments you have
you know any compute resources you have
any additional artifacts you're
generating from that modeling process
and so keeping track of these
environment or these artifacts across
environments can be tricky in itself but
you also have to think about the
iterative nature of ml right we're
building different versions of these
things as we go through different
environments so not only do we have to
manage them across environments we have
to manage those versions so they all fit
together really nicely we need to have
the version of the model match the right
version of the data match the right
version of the environments and keep
moving that through the entire process
it gets really delicate and really
challenging so again being able to
answer these questions of like what
features that was my model trained on
which version of data was my model
trained on gets really difficult as the
number of artifacts start to grow
Okay so we've kind of framed things up a
little bit
um let's talk about Delta and demo flow
so if you're unfamiliar with Delta
Dental flow they're both open source
pieces of Technology I'll start with
Delta so Delta itself is an open source
storage format or a framework rather and
the easiest way I like to think about
Delta is versioned parquet files of the
transaction log so if you're familiar
with parquet think think parquet first
right we get all of the great benefits
of parquet the compression we get all
the metadata that's tracked in the the
headers and Footers of parquet files
that's awesome
now when we add this versioning on top
of that what we get is we get the
ability to look and see how those
parquet files have changed over time
which can be really helpful when we
think about matching those versions of
models to versions of data in the
deployment process
and then on top of these versions We
have the transaction log which is kind
of like the the single source of truth
it's where all of the operations against
the table are tracked so you can see how
these versions of chain are changing but
you can also see who's making these
changes right who is rewriting
overwriting these tables who's merging
certain tables which again can be really
important when we think about access to
data and upper level environments
um in terms of interacting with Delta it
plays really nicely with spark which if
you've seen Delta you've probably seen
it in in context with spark but also
plays really nice with a couple other
things
um namely it plays really well with
python because of some of the the rust
binding so we'll talk about that in in a
little bit
um and then ml flow so ml flow is again
another open source framework that is
designed to make managing the machine
learning lifecycle easier now
uh that's like really kind of salesy and
like me just like waving my hands of
like oh it's like all great it makes
everything better but I'm going to
attempt to explain it and kind of show
how this actually works
um and so there's several components to
mlflow but the components are really
designed to
um to address different parts of the
machine learning process so the first
piece is there's a tracking or like a
locking API with mlflow that can be
really helpful in experimentation and
reproducibility so as you go through and
are generating these different parts of
a any data science experiment think your
hyper parameters think the model think
the data think the feature set think the
environment think all those things right
those things can be logged directly to
this ml flow tracking of this locking
API
so again you can keep track of all the
metadata that's associated with a model
itself which contributes right back to
reproducibility right as I think about
moving this model across different
places we have all of the necessary
metadata to reproduce those results in
upper level environments
um the other pieces of mlflow again can
contribute to making deployment a little
bit easier and this is one that I'm
going to kind of like wave my hands at
right now and say that just bear with me
for like four slides and I'll explain
this I think in more detail but
essentially the way that mlflow can
package up these models and make them
much more self-containing means that we
can avoid a lot of the dependency
management or dependency frustrations I
should say when it comes to deploying
models down the line
and then the one of the last pieces of
ml flow is there's a model registration
component and so again this is thinking
kind of the same way that we are
versioning data with Delta we are
versioning models with mlflow to be able
to track Which models and which versions
of certain models are at What stages of
the process right so knowing which
models are in development Which models
are in production which versions of
Which models are in development and
production all of that can be tracked
like I said through that that
registration piece
the other nice part of mlflow it's kind
of bring your own framework in the sense
of you can there's no dependency of
having to rely on only training models
with sklearn you can bring you know
escaler and you can bring a custom
algorithm you could bring tensorflow
Keras Pi towards anything
um can play nicely with mlflows you're
not really Limited in like whatever
Library you're using it like I said
we'll play nicely with them also there
um and then in terms of interacting with
it right there's a lot of ways to do it
rely on on python but again there's CLI
rest on and job and all that good stuff
okay
let's talk about deployment patterns now
so there's really three main deployment
patterns that we see
um and all these deployment patterns are
shaped around which artifacts are being
moved right that's kind of the first
question you should always ask yourself
is which artifacts am I moving across
different environments
um and so these are kind of in no order
at all but the first one we'll start
with is deploy model so again we're just
thinking about the flow of artifacts
right now we're not thinking about the
automation of how these things are
flowing just like the pattern
um so in the deploy model scenario
that's where again you train your model
in your Dev environment
this kind of relies on the fact that you
have access to production data in Dev
which might not always be the case
sometimes it is sometimes it's not but
you train your model in Dev and then you
take this model binary and that's what's
moving to staging you maybe run some
tests in staging you know your test pass
and you move to production but that
binary is what's being moved across
environments
the second one is deploy code now this
one can be much more helpful especially
if you're in a scenario where you don't
have access to production data in Dev
which again happens a lot in like
regulated Industries especially when
you're dealing with with like personal
Health Data all that kind of stuff so
the code mechanism is or pattern rather
is where you
um your code is moving from environment
to environment so you have your Devon
environment your code is developed there
and you know you go ahead and merge it
to staging you run your unit tests your
integration tests and your staging
environment and then pending you know
the successful running of those tests
you push into prod and then prod your
entire model pipeline is retrained so
again that's where you can have access
to your production data a service
account has access to your production
data you can rerun the whole pipeline
but by just moving like set that code
and then the third is a hybrid approach
it's some version of of both
um in terms of like the patterns of
these again these kind of vary just
depending on
um the scenario and permissions and
things like that but it's really some
version of deploying both the code and
the model throughout the process so an
example this would be like your model is
trained in Dev you promote your model
binary and your code into staging uh you
know you run all your tests and then you
go ahead and only promote your code into
production and retrain your model in
production and you can access production
data all that good stuff
um thing to think about here especially
with the hybrid approach is much like
anything else the more things you add
the more complexity You Get Right Moving
one box is easy moving a whole house is
a little bit harder so as you you know
increase the number of artifacts that
you move you have to understand that
there's likely going to be an increased
cost to automate that process now it
won't necessarily be linear right
because likely the mechanism you use to
move one artifact you can use to move
multiple but that's just you know more
pieces of the puzzle that you're moving
together
something to think about as you are you
know kind of understanding which
artifact you're moving across different
deployment patterns
we've talked about deployment patterns
let's now bring this thing together
right if where do Delta and mlflow fit
into this piece
um so one thing again that's really
important that I've kind of started to
talk about is this idea of data
reproducibility so when we're trying to
reproduce a model or trying to move it
across different environments we have to
be able to map versions of data to the
model the same way that you need lineage
and data engineering you need that same
lineage and machine learning except it
just is a little bit different right
it's lineage between your model and your
data and any other artifacts now you'll
see the diagrams for both deploy code
and deploy model on here for kind of how
the versions are important this is also
still relevant I want to be clear for
the hybrid approach but that diagram
just gets way too messy to put on a
slide
the gist here is that regardless of what
whatever pattern you're looking at the
need to version your data to be able to
map which data goes or which version of
which data goes to your model or to your
code is incredibly important so let's
look at the like deploy code for example
um you know we build our our model or
build our code in our Dev environment we
have some version of data that we want
to check in there same thing the code
gets promoted we move to staging maybe
run our tests on a different subset of
data and then finally as our code moves
through production we are training our
model now on production data but have to
have a certain version of production
data another thing to think about here
too is a permission structure is
changing right we shouldn't have users
have access to data in our prod
environment that's likely going to be
service accounts and so having that
audit path of who is accessing what data
when is also going to be really valuable
especially in these like highly
regulated Industries
so this is where the Delta paste really
starts to come in so
um like I mentioned before Delta is
version parquet files of the transaction
log and this combination of the parquet
files plus the transaction log allows us
to do what's called time travel which is
the ability to view historic versions of
the data so again this is the the piece
that allows us to take a model and map
it directly to not only a table or a
location of files but the exact version
of those whether that version is done by
a version number or even a timestamp so
again if you say you have a model that
was trained two weeks ago you need to
reproduce it into a different
environment or for for like audit
reasons you can say I want to look at my
data of what it looked like exactly two
weeks ago to be able to fully reproduce
the results of this model
um and so one of the other pieces here
is like I said that transaction log
tracks a whole bunch of other things
besides those versions of parquet files
attracts a bunch of metadata of things
like who has access to what so when we
think about tracking any events against
the table we can ensure that the right
users are touching the right data in the
right environment so again in Dev we
would expect our data scientists to be
the ones creating tables merging tables
overwriting them Etc but as we move into
those upper environments we would expect
that only to become things like service
accounts right that like humans don't
have access to or that humans are not
touching the data that service accounts
are to ensure that we are producing
those High Fidelity results of that
well-rounded deployment system
so uh you oftentimes probably seen if
you've seen Delta you've seen it a lot
of times a couple of spark
um but not all ml requires the power of
spark right um but all of them all ml
requires this reproducibility piece of
data so all of them require Delta but we
don't need spark and so
um
there is a Delta RS Library which is
they prove Delta RS provides rather the
rust bindings or the rust base for the
python bindings which means that you can
just use vanilla Python and Delta you
don't need to be using spark anymore and
this plays right into the pandas
integration so in data science right
pandas is the the stand pretty much the
standard for
for single mode data science so you can
read from Delta directly to pandas using
this the Delta table apis as well as the
two pandas function so you result with
the pan and data frame and then in the
reverse if you have a Panos data frame
in memory and want to write it to a
Delta table to get you know that
versioning to get all of the access to
that metadata in the transaction log you
can do that using the right Delta Lake
function too
so spark is no longer needed the spark
is not only the the way it's interact
with Delta you can interact with it
using vanilla python
okay let's now talk about ml flow
deployment optimizations
so I kind of waved my hands earlier this
is where I actually start to tell you
like explain a little bit more why
um so if we think about making
deployment easier the number one thing
that's going to help us is we need to
identify what we need for deployment
right what do we need to move things how
are we going to move them and all of
those those pieces so to answer that
question it's going to be entirely
dependent on your pattern right if
you're deploying code if you're
deploying model if you're deploying some
you know hybrid of both but regardless
of whatever pattern you're using you
will likely need to deploy some aspect
of your code of the model itself of the
hyper parameters you'll need to keep
track of the metrics the environments
all of that stuff right and that's where
that logging API really comes in uh you
can track all of the metadata that's
associated with your experiment again
those things that will be required for
you to recreate in upper level
environments as part of the ml flow that
tracking API
and so on top of that tracking API when
you log models there's actually this
like I said that packaging format kind
of comes in which is what you're seeing
on the screenshot right here so this is
a model that I built and logged in
mlflow just a like a vanilla escalarn
model
and there's a lot of things that are
logged here but I really want to call
attention to these like these flavors
um so you'll see that at the bottom just
below the purple box there's what's
called it's a little hard but it's it
says escaler in here and it's
um it's the native flavor I like to call
it but every time you log a model with
ML flow two flavors are logged the
native flavor which you'll see here so
you can see that it's again the escalary
model serialized with Cloud pickle gives
you the version of cloud pickle awesome
right I can now serve this model on
anything that's going to be able to
understand and SK learn and use an
escaler model
but you'll see the second flavor that's
logged here is a python function and
there's kind of twofold value to this
python function the first is that you'll
see the python function is
self-containing so it points to a condo
yaml that includes all of the required
dependencies needed to use this model
for a serving so it includes like I said
the condo yaml
and it points to the mlfl loader module
which is really the wrapper around SK
learn to be able to load this model in
and out of using just python the
prediction function and the python
version so the nice part here is I can
now take this model and serve it on
anything that understands python right I
don't have to worry about making sure my
VM or my deployment region understands
an SQL model and can manage all those
Downstream dependencies if it's got
python on on it I am good to go I'm good
to serve so it kind of opens the door
and eases that burden of all of that
environment management by logging this
python function so that's kind of one
value piece this python function
the other piece is
um kind of pertains more to like the
version or the inference at scale so
like I said I deploy this model with
um s or trains model rather with
ascalearn
um just a regular single node model
right
um but this python function actually has
a vectorized UDF that's built in which
means that I can use this to distribute
my model for inference so again I build
this model with sklearn say I need to
now apply it to gigabytes petabytes
terabytes of data right I need to scale
this this model out for inference I
don't have to change the look of the
training code right I can keep the
training code AS is I can use this
python function Leverage The Spark UDF
in this python function and then apply
inference across you know an entire
cluster of machines to do inference at
scale and so the way that this actually
works is this vectorizudf works is it
uses Apache Arrow underneath the covers
to really minimize the serialization
cost between the jvm process which is
happening which is what's happening in
spark and the python process which is
happening on top of the jvm and if
you're curious to know more about
scaling code and kind of these these
vectorized udfs I'd actually talk
tomorrow by some colleagues at 10 15.
that will talk much much more about kind
of scaling this single node code with
spark and pandas so
um this like I said this second part of
the Python function of having this UDF
it can be really useful when we think
about scaling out inference of a single
node model
okay uh let's talk cicd
candidly cic scares me scared me I
should say past tense
um like I said I come from like a data
science math background automation tools
just like not we're not really exciting
to me
um which is why I have this like Jeff of
SpongeBob like clutching pencil this is
me like trying to be like what is
Jenkins
um so to provide a little bit more
context uh let's revisit these
appointment patterns right last time we
talked about that we talked about how
things move just like the pattern of
which things move now it's layered it's
more complexity not only do we want to
know how these things move this needs to
happen in an automated way right we need
to be able to Auto to move my model or
move my code or move both without me
having to touch anything or touch maybe
one button per se
so this is where again we revisit this
idea of being automation first
so regardless of whatever artifacts like
I said are being deployed whether you're
going through the deploy code approach
the deploy model approach or the hybrid
there should be automation that's going
to move these things from one place to
another so again if we think about the
deploy model piece here
we're deploying that model binary right
there's some level of code management
again using whatever flavor of get you
want but then there's also going to be
again that automation piece that's going
to move the model physically move that
model from your Dev environment to
staging run your tests and then move it
from staging to prod and then run your
jobs and prod
um in the deploy code sense right
similar idea here except we're deploying
code right so there's again another
level of code management
um we have our code in Dev this is where
the branching structure really comes
into play here of managing branches
across Dev staging and prod to kind of
Point Automation in the right direction
and then again with deploy both these
patterns kind of vary but same idea
right there's some level of code version
that needs to happen and then a level of
movement of these artifacts
um and so beyond the automation piece of
the movement the other important piece
here is triggers and triggering and so
triggers are really what's going to kick
these things off tell the automation to
say hey this is how we get started
um and so I'll take kind of deploy code
AS example here so if we think about
that to deploy code approach we you know
write some code committed to our Dev
Branch we then create a pull request
from Dev to staging and that pull
request can act as a trigger so that
pull request is going to tell my
automation server to say hey okay let's
move this code from Dev to staging let's
run my tests pending those you know
successful tests we can merge that
Branch together and that the successful
merge from Dev to staging can kick off
another PR that's going to merge the
code from staging to prod and then
deploy the jobs into fraud and all I had
to do was create one pull request to Dev
and it moved my code and deployed my
code all the way into prod right so
those triggers can be really important
and that's why you see oftentimes like
PR's especially when you're deploying
code really common trigger
because I don't honestly kind of make
one PR and it will kind of can carry you
through the rest of the process
pull requests are one of many ways to go
ahead and Define triggers you can do API
requests there's a lot of ways there's
web hooks you can integrate with but
definitely for deploy code pull requests
is really useful tool to lead on
um this chart is not exhaustive at all
this is just kind of like I said some
common tools cicd encompasses a lot of
things
and I kind of want to like I said call
your time into a couple things on here
we'll start with orchestration so again
when you think about like what's going
to be that mechanism that's going to
move things to set up the trigger and
move things Jenkins can be a really
useful tool for that it's open source so
it plays nicely with a lot of things
there's also like I said several sort of
managed Solutions most of the
code versioning
softwares or products like GitHub big
bucket Azure devops have their own like
automation server Associated so like
bitbucket has pipelines GitHub has
GitHub actions and devops has devops
pipelines so again depending on kind of
what you're using for code management
you can kind of stitch together the
right cic tools or the right automation
tool I should say on top of that again
there's some notes on here about like
web hooks so again web hooks can be
another means for triggering certain
things depending on like what your
process looks like
as well as like testing Frameworks and
stuff like rely on Pi test for honestly
I rely on pie tests quite a bit for
running tests and staging and production
but like this is not an exhaustive list
it's just kind of throwing a couple
things out there so when you see these
tools you kind of know how and where
they fit into the process the last thing
I'll talk about on this slide is the
mlflow projects piece so again that's
like that that mlfl model I talked about
of easing the burden of environment
management by packaging all of your ml
code into into one cohesive product that
contains the environment so you can just
like I said deploy it on on whatever
your deployment mechanism is whether
that's a virtual machine whether that's
on-prem whatever it may be
okay so
um how do I approach this like I said
automation first is like the whole
mentality here right
um there's no unfortunately I wish I
could tell you there is but there's no
single right way to stitch all these CI
CD tools together right there's so many
of them
um in terms of like how to approach like
where do I even start
um honestly security I hate to say it no
no offense of anyone's security
um but uh security can approve or
disprove of a lot of Technologies and so
I've been in a lot of situations where
people are really passionate about using
a certain tool but for some reason
security says Nope we use this other one
here so if you're ever looking to know
okay where do I even start I would
recommend talking to your security teams
and seeing what's approved but it's
already in use
um the other things to think about are
things like do you want to say open
source Centric right
um You can do all of this with open
source tools you don't necessarily need
any of those managed tools
um things like latency requirements can
be really important here so if you're
serving a real-time model understanding
how that can contribute to some of the
automation pieces in here and then the
last piece I would say is like
unification
um especially like I'm sure a lot of
software engineering teams already have
Automation in place rely on those folks
right like they have quite a bit of
knowledge of what tools are already out
there and already exist in your your
ecosystem and providing that consistency
again kind of lowers that learning curve
that's necessary for any CIS for any
deployment piece
oops
okay wrapping things up so we talked
about the deployment patterns again this
is all defined by the artifacts that
you're moving um so when you think about
where do I even start think about your
artifacts first right put it in in terms
of artifacts
um and then we talked about kind of
regardless of that pattern those data
audit pieces and the reproducible
reproducibility pieces of your data is
super important and that's where you can
really lean on Delta and not like
versions parquet files to the
transaction log uh to to lead you
through there to provide that lineage of
model to version data
um I talked about mlfl like I said
um but I didn't honestly talk about
every piece of mlflow we didn't really
Touch Too Much on the registry which is
again kind of another piece here but
amongst many other things mlflow can
provide some of those built-in
optimizations so that's that Vector as
UDF and that python flavor or python
function flavor as well as the tracking
to track all of your metadata to further
help that story of reproducibility as
you shift your artifacts across
different environments
um the last piece again is cicd toy
ironically it's designed to further
simplify sometimes I feel like initially
it's more complex in simplifying things
but longer term right it's designed to
to simplify and automate uh your
deployment processes so keeping those
those couple things in mind of like
where to start of those tooling really
all about going to be like security
Centric unification all that stuff last
thing is that gifs are much easier to
put in a slide deck than I ever thought
I don't know why I thought it was like
really hard uh turns out it's just copy
and pasting a link if anyone's new to
that
um but yeah that's all I've got for you
guys today for everyone today and I
think we can now open to questions
all right
thank you so much Mary Grace any
questions
I just had a quick question about Delta
and like the parquet files like are the
parques files stored with your models
then or like how how does that happen
yeah so you can essentially track the
version numbers with as part of like a
piece of metadata that's tracked in the
mlfl experiment you so you can log your
data right but what's really happening
when you log things is just log into
blob storage on the back end so it could
be redundant so the easiest way I found
it to do it honestly is just taking that
version number or timestamp logging it
with your mlfl experiments and then you
can access like you directly can access
like that version you can also log like
the path to right so you have the table
path and the version
awesome any other questions
just as a follow-up uh does that mean
that in order to use data versioning via
Delta or is it Delta leak no Delta right
Delta uh that we have to use ml flow no
so you don't you don't necessarily have
to right um it's all about like bridging
that you can use mlflow without Delta
you can use Delta without mufflow
they're independent of each other but
they work together to produce to like be
able to provide that lineage
do uh do either of the um deployment
patterns that you mentioned do do either
of them work better with changing
dependencies between environments
but especially for
eign
requirements.txt file that's just a file
that your versioning with the rest of
your code in a repository
um so I'd say like if anything that's
gonna be a little bit easier the model
binary it's somewhat limiting if that's
a fixed thing that you're moving
um and you it's hard to access like
again the dependencies in there so I
would say the deploy code is a little
bit more conducive for managing
different environments or dependencies
across different environments
any more questions
one question I had was what was the
moment where that CI CD fear was kind of
alleviated it's still there sometimes
yeah I'll let you know
awesome well thank you so much Mary
Grace yeah thank you
[Applause]